cut out negativity just cut out the
people who don't serve you sometimes
those are friends that you've had from
kindergarten or high school or
university you're in the Friendship out
of convenience now there's a lot of
people who you might need to let go of
you might need to just let them go They
don't serve you anymore you've walked
your parallel path together and now
they've gone out well they've probably
just stayed here while you've gone out
here they don't serve you anymore and it
doesn't mean you have to be a mean
person or cold or rude you're just not
on the same path anymore and a lot of
people fight that because you're worried
about finding new friends or being
around new people and so you stick with
these people who don't serve you anymore
and that's a mistake that they're
keeping you where you're at because
their negativity they're complaining
their unwillingness to change their
pessimism their laziness they're not
chasing down goals that becomes toxic
even if you're trying to be a beacon
even if you're trying to be the person
who pulls everybody up if all you're
doing is trying to pull other people up
and there's nothing pulling you up
you're gonna be limited for life